welcome back the Justice Department
confirmed this week that Attorney
General Jeff Sessions is considering
appointing a special counsel to
investigate several matters related to
Hillary Clinton one of those issues is
the sale of uranium 1 to a Russian back
company back in 2010 Hillary Clinton's
State Department signed off on the deal
despite the fact that it gave Russia
control of only 20% of US rhenium
capacity critics allege that Hillary
okay the deal because of some hefty
donations to the Clinton Foundation the
National reviews Andy McCarthy wrote
today Iranian Hwan has never primarily
been a national-security controversy
it's a corruption controversy joining us
now from Tallahassee a man who knows
more about this perhaps than anyone else
Peter Schweitzer is the president of the
Government Accountability Institute and
author of the huge bestseller Clinton
cash so Peter I've noticed this
happening over the last mmm 48 hours
especially number of people some
Republicans some Democrats and always
the Clintons of course there is no there
there this is just a fantasy cooked up
in the mind of some guy who wrote a book
called Clinton cash and it's grabbed
onto by the conservative media you know
pay no attention to the scandal behind
the curtain yeah that's that's the
standard line Laura the problem for that
narrative is there's plenty of evidence
the uranium one saga most people are
aware of this 2010 sale of uranium one
to the Russian government that was
approved by the Obama administration but
the story really begins in 2005 when
Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton helped
this Canadian investor Frank juicer
who's the founder of uranium one acquire
these uranium assets in Kazakhstan which
is a massive producer of uranium and and
what we have in very clear evidence is
the video testimony of the Russian sorry
the Kazakh Minister of Kev's atom prom
which is the Kazakh atomic agency what
does he say in this video deposition
Mukhtar yakushev his name says that they
granted that concession
Frank Giustra because Hillary Clinton
then a senator blackmailed and
threatened Kasich officials saying she
would not cooperate with him getting us
money that she would not meet with any
Kazakh officials until the concession
was granted after that concession was
granted by Kazakh officials Frank
Giustra sent 30 million dollars to the
Clinton Foundation so we already have
the oral testimony by this Kazakh
official it's never been disputed and by
the way Laura in that testimony he
describes in detail how this deal went
down he talks about a Clinton Foundation
employee named Tim Phillips who
pressured him when Tim Phillips was
contacted and asked about this video he
did not respond he changed his online
resume removing hit the reference to his
employment through the Clinton
Foundation that's just one piece of
evidence so this is not a fantasy cooked
up this is something foreign government
officials have talked about why is Andy
McCarthy saying this is just corruption
it has no national security implications
I mean our viewers here uranium and they
think nuclear power and that's important
and nuclear other things but Andy's like
it's not it's not a national security
question well I would I would
respectfully disagree with Andy I have
enormous respect for him what's
happening is a lot of people think
uranium one was totally about the
uranium in the United States the United
States is not a big uranium producer the
problem is that's not true
uranium one was a company when the
Russians bought it and still is a
company today that has massive uranium
deposits around the world in Kazakhstan
in Australia they have them in Africa
they have them in the United States if
you were to look simply at the uranium
that they have in the United States the
20% you could say it's pretty small it
doesn't amount to a lot the problem is
that's a small sliver of the entire
assets that that uranium one represents
and by the way this is very important
uranium one when it was bought by the
Russians in 2010 the money for that deal
was publicly in
by Vladimir Putin himself and that deal
was authorized by Vladimir Putin himself
so certainly Vladimir Putin saw national
security interest from Russia's
standpoint in acquiring uranium 1 so
we're always looking for the Putin
connection to elected officials you ever
look at a picture Putin did you ever
have a White Russian in a restaurant I
mean Peter I saw you at the Russian Tea
Room once in New York that's a scandal
do you think you are you committed to
this idea I know if you've thought it
through about the special prosecutor I
think there's actually a good argument
to be made that you really don't need a
special prosecutor that I guess if we
believe in the Justice Department that
they would actually pursue possible
crimes intimidation of witnesses
bribery all the things that we're
hearing about when it comes to the
Clintons and this stuff you can get a
great line prosecutor to do this with a
great staff but you know we got a lot of
people Jim Jordan may want to they want
a special prosecutor and another special
prosecutor to investigate this yeah I
mean that's a great question here's the
problem we know for a fact the FBI has
in its possession another tape an audio
tape that was basically recorded by this
FBI informant that's going to be coming
forward I have not heard the tape but
I've heard about the tape from people at
the FBI and that audio tape apparently
is Russian officials with this uranium
company talking about making donations
to the Clinton Foundation to gain
favorable action that tape was given to
Department of Justice prosecutors the
FBI field office requesting the ability
to wiretap and to survey the Clinton
Foundation the Obama Justice Department
came back and said no not enough
evidence so you know my point with an
independent counsel my point with the
Independent Counsel Laura is look this
is so political I think the way to deal
with this is precisely in this manner
it's important it's complex it goes to
the to the reason people think there's
so much corruption in Washington DC and
the fact that there's a double standard
some people have accounts and others are
not the law should apply to both parties
individuals in both parties should be
held to account Peter it's always great
seeing you thank you so much